the Norse God hame thou has recently
grown in popularity mostly due to his
role in the Marvel Thor movies but who
is Haim thou and what is his story Haim
dad was known as the ever vigilant
guardian of Asgard he watched over as
God from the hemming bjorg otherwise
known as the sky cliffs which sit upon
the Bifrost the Rainbow Bridge leading
into Asgard Haendel possessed
eagle like a vision being able to see
for hundreds of miles in day on nights
his hearing was so acute that he could
even hear blades of grass growing Haim
doll watches and listens with his horn
ready to sound if intruders approach
Asgard
there are suggestions from verses in Old
Norse poetry that him thou was once the
father of humankind and that he may have
even established the structure and
hierarchy in the North Society in many
North tales men often referred to as
sons of ham though like many of the
North Scots aimed al is a son of Odin
the case of him those mother is a
peculiar one as he was born from 9 of
them all of them sisters Haim Dells job
was at lonely in solitary one because he
was so driven to perform his duty and
protect the people of Asgard
he didn't seem to have much of a
connection with the other gods one of
him there was more notice relationships
was of that of frail the goddess of love
when Loki stole Freya's prized pendin
came down left his post and took the
form of a seal in order to face Loki and
recover Freya's pendant
when the Ragnarok had come the gods knew
that their doom was at hand they heard
the dire call of hemdale horn signaling
that the Giants had crossed a Rainbow
Bridge and were ready to enter Asgard
amongst the Giants was loki hame thou
had always despised Loki Loki would
regularly leave as God without informing
him down as the Watchmen of Asgard
hame they'll demand that Loki would be
prevented from leaving and returning
whenever he chose only Odin was to come
and go in secret confirming his
suspicions of Loki were correct aim
they'll relish the chance to slay his
nemesis as the world around them burned
and began to sink into the sea hame thou
and Loki equally matched slay each other
if you've enjoyed this video then please
go ahead and leave it a like consider
subscribing if folklore mythology is
something that interests you if you have
anything you'd like to discuss or have
any ideas for future videos then please
go ahead
and let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained